what was that study that looked at
penalty takers trying to win versus
penalty takers trying not to lose so if
you're taking a penalty to put your team
through the pressure is actually less
than the pressure on you if you're
taking a penalty to keep your team in
because our brains have evolved a bias
towards loss if you think back to our
evolutionary history if you face with a
rustle in the bushes and you make a
wrong decision then it can come out of
the Bush and eat you pretty quickly and
we don't want to have a situation where
we are complacent and where we mistake
something those kinds of evolutionary
buyers biases that evolved many years
ago are still with us today in in
football stadiums when it comes to
penalty shootouts if you're taking a
penalty which if you miss is going to
put your team out that loss is really
Weighing on your mind way more than if
you know you're going to score and
you're going to put your team through